testing hygiene measures vaccinations
organization the pandemic has presented
new challenges to people all over the
world
for many of these problems there were no
standard solutions
a lot of time and effort went into
implementing new ideas
in this program we show how scientists
inventors and ordinary people found ways
to make the best of an unprecedented
situation
like in spain where researchers have
designed an intelligent ffp2 mask with
an alarm function
since the pandemic outbreak in early
2020 masks have become an indispensable
ally in preventing the spread of covet
19.
but in spite of the evidence in favor of
them in reducing community transmission
people who have to wear a mask for hours
on end agree
that it's not always easy
some days especially at the start of the
pandemic i had a headache and felt
drowsy
since you can't breathe as well and
you're working all day you may get more
tired than usual
the co2 concentration between a person's
face and an ffp2 mask is higher than
usual because the air that's exhaled
gets trapped inhaling this carbon
dioxide can lead to health effects such
as headache or fatigue
when i wear the mask for a long time and
it's busy i get tired and my nose and
throat get dry
i have to run to the kitchen drink water
breathe a bit and get back to work
to help mask wearers avoid these issues
a multi-disciplinary research team made
up of engineers and chemical scientists
from the university of granada has
developed an intelligent mask that
alerts wearers on their smartphones when
recommended co2 limits are exceeded
the intelligent mask has a sensor
meaning a way to measure something in
the air between your face and the mask
so this co2 sensor is equipped with the
electronics that will measure the color
change in the sensor
and transmit that information to a
smartphone
so a standard ffp2 mask can be turned
into an intelligent mask that monitors
gas concentration by placing a special
electronic sticker inside the mask
the sticker inserted inside the mask is
a system that consists of two parts
on one side there's what's called
readout electronics which is printed
with conductive ink on a flexible
plastic and transparent substrate as you
can see
on the other side is the chemical part
of the sensor that changes its color
depending on the co2 concentration
to notify users if they've reached the
recommended co2 limits inside the mask
the research team has designed a special
mobile app
the user has a mobile app to read the
carbon dioxide concentration
with nfc technology
the same technology used for wireless
payments
users would simply have to hold their
smartphone close to the mask
it automatically detects this sticker
and reads the co2 concentration inside
the mask
the software alerts users through a
traffic light display red or green
if they need to ventilate
although mask mandates have been lifted
in many countries many workers are still
required to wear them so the researchers
believe there's a demand
the team is willing to transfer the
technology to any industry that may be
interested in it
alongside masks coronavirus tests have
become our constant companions whether a
quick test at home a lollipop test at
school or a pcr test analyzed in a lab
but even with an extensive testing
infrastructure some people get tested
less often than they should they don't
have a test kit don't have time or just
don't want to but there is a way to test
everyone all the time and without anyone
even noticing
this is waste water
it comes from zabrooken in western
germany and is purified at the largest
sewage treatment plant in xyland
25 000 cubic meters of wastewater on dry
days
enough to fill more than
thirty 130 bathtubs though in rainy
weather that amount can triple
tina fullerton conducts wastewater
analysis
recently she's been checking sewage
samples for the coronavirus believing
that this could be a better way to
detect rising infection rates than covid
test results
the advantage of monitoring wastewater
is that it gives us data on everyone
who's infected since everyone has to go
to the toilet
and everything we excrete ends up at the
sewage treatment plant
since we get human waste from everyone
in the plant's catchment area we can
also find fragments of the virus that
infected people excrete into the waste
water
so we can catch unreported cases too as
not everyone knows that they're infected
or gets tested
the sewage at the treatment plant is
already tested for harmful substances
nitrate concentration and ph value
an auto sampler collects a bottle every
two hours
benjamin wolf examines the samples at
the same time each day
an extra sample is now taken twice a
week for the coronavirus monitoring
pilot project
this bottle is for our coronavirus
sampling
the larger bottle is for our sampling
our daily checks
and this large bottle will be kept
frozen for a month so we always have a
reserve sample
almost two years ago zuzana lachna from
the technical university of darmstadt
found that sampling wastewater can show
how quickly and widely coronavirus has
spread through a region
back then she and her team were
searching for an early warning system
for coven 19 waves and found it in
wastewater
her method could even detect how quickly
different variants of the virus were
spreading in a given area
the data could be used to estimate the
infection rate in the plant's catchment
area and decide whether to do more covid
testing or less and whether to relax
covered restrictions depending on
wastewater values
many countries including the netherlands
spain and the u.s quickly adopted the
system in part because it's cheaper than
conducting hundreds of thousands of
individual covets
the domstadt researchers offered their
services to nearby frankfurt too but its
health department declined
as did authorities in other german
cities
it's really a pity we tried to speak
with the health department as we feel
this data is very sensible and useful
but it went nowhere
we're not doing this for ourselves
we want to share this information with
the authorities and health department to
help fight the pandemic and that
requires communication
communication on austral
so now there's a cheap and effective
system to monitor covet waves that's
being used internationally
yet many german authorities have chosen
to ignore it
friedrich hetzel deals with safe and
sustainable water management
can he explain this refusal
maybe it's due to our way of thinking
waste water monitoring provides a trend
analysis
from wastewater analysis we don't get
any numbers where we can irrefutably say
that for example
in the catchment area of a sewage plant
one thousand of a city's fifty thousand
residents are currently covet positive
positive this weekend
that's why health authorities initially
said
we don't wanna rely on these trends when
it comes to making predictions and
implementing measures
now 20 german municipalities are taking
part in the wastewater monitoring pilot
project even more had applied to do so
currently the wastewater samples from
across germany that are being tested for
the coronavirus are sent to a central
lab by mail
it's hoped that eventually testing could
be done on the spot
then the results would be available even
more quickly
masks tests many times during the
pandemic we were faced with issues for
which we had no off-the-shelf standard
solutions new ideas were needed around
the world inventors set to work to help
themselves and others our reporter lars
halter spoke to professor doug hanna
from boston university about some of
these solutions including a diy air
filter from the hardware store
professor hannah the pandemic threw a
lot of problems at people especially
those in government positions and in
institutions tasked with keeping people
safe and solutions were sometimes hard
to come by but there seemed to be a
handful of inventors that came up with
pretty smart ways to help
we found one particularly interesting
the corsi rosentel box for air
filtration can you tell me a little bit
more about that
yeah
yeah absolutely so the the corsi
rosenthal box is at its core it's just
essentially four filters taped together
with a fan uh and the goal is to provide
a boost to um
to ventilation by and filtration um i
actually have an example here this is a
sort of smaller version than it's
typically uh used but it's as you can
see it's four filters some cardboard
tape uh and a fan on top
um it's what is really neat about this
is it is about 60 to 80 dollars in
supplies it takes about 30 minutes to
make it can be adapted based on what's
available in a local hardware store but
once you have one it can provide a
really substantial boost to ventilation
your team has built up a whole database
full of interesting inventions all
related to the pandemic which ones did
you find particularly interesting
yeah so my team has been tracking
hundreds of organizations that cropped
up all over the world to address the
sort of social and economic and human
health impacts and some of the
inventions that they've created have
been just absolutely wonderful there
were things like intubation boxes which
protect doctors and medical personnel
from aerosol contamination when putting
patients on ventilators there were
low-cost oxygen concentrators there were
all manner of different masks and
respirators made out of whatever locally
available materials there happened to be
uv disinfectant chambers for reusing and
sterilizing
personal protective equipment
and you know hundreds or thousands of
other hardware inventions
there were also really neat social
innovations and i think for me some of
the ones that stand out the most are all
of the effort and the sort of clever
thinking that went into organizing
people who were remote during a pandemic
to work together to accomplish things so
for example uh there were groups that
got together to organize these sort of
complex supply chains to locate
professional-grade n95 masks that were
in people's homes and get them and
redistribute them to hospitals to where
they needed to be
similarly there were groups that
designed masks tested different mask
materials pre-assembled kits and got
them out to home psoas who could make
masks and then again get them uh to
front line staff
and the sort of human uh organizing
aspect there is is not trivial it's a
really difficult thing to do in the best
of circumstances and this was during a
pandemic so even though we often think
just about those hardware solutions
there was a tremendous amount of
ingenuity uh just getting everyone to
work together under really difficult
conditions
now some of these really smart solutions
could not really be used by hospitals or
schools because of rules and regulations
has the process held up progress in
fighting the pandemic
so there's a real difficult challenge
here um we need rules and regulations
when we're talking about people's health
we're talking about medical devices and
medical settings we need rules and
regulations to make sure that our
treatments and our devices work uh that
they're manufactured uh correctly that
they're stored correctly everything like
this the challenge though is that in a
pandemic you also do need to move fast
and in this sense rules and regulations
did in many cases pose a big impediment
to people who were trying to get in and
help so we saw hospitals for example
that were not able to accept donated
personal protective equipment and thus
had to do without we similarly uh still
actually see schools turning down
ventilation boxes uh and filter boxes
like this um so on one hand uh it's you
know
these regulations matter we need them on
the other hand they absolutely do become
a source of inflexibility uh when we
need to move fast in a pandemic
professor hannah thank you very much
thank you
new ideas are also important as we find
ways to live with the coronavirus into
the future
keeping distance and wearing masks don't
seem like long-term solutions because a
large part of the population is already
against the idea
now researchers in finland are working
on a nasal spray that can be used easily
as needed to block the coronavirus
[Music]
it's 9 a.m in finland's capital and
these young researchers are already
immersed in their work
in this lab at the university of
helsinki they have joined the global
race to end the pandemic caused by the
novel coronavirus
however their weapon in this fight is
not a vaccine but a nasal spray so far
their project looks promising
the aim is to provide short-term
protection
so
in in pre-clinical
studies in animal models we have
gained a strong
protection against viral infection when
we have applied
eight hours before
the in the inhibitor and also even four
hours after the infection
anna mecca and her team say their
research shows the spray protects
against covert 19 variants such as
omicron and delta the innovation could
be especially helpful to high-risk
groups
there really is a need for complementing
applications
in addition to vaccines
i have to address that this is not meant
for replacing vaccines but to complement
their action
the finished nasal spray does not remove
coronaviruses but inactivates them with
a blocker it forms a protective shield
in the airways when coronaviruses enter
the nose and mouth the molecules of the
spray block the spike proteins of the
virus from taking hold
pharmaceutical companies around the
globe are following the development of
new coronavirus drugs carefully
at the same time that vaccines started
to be developed companies began looking
into drugs to treat covet 19 related
symptoms
as with this nasal spray study the
underlying research is often prompted by
the researchers themselves and only
later do companies join as partners
but right now we think that vaccines are
our number one tool to exit the
pandemics
finland has one of europe's highest
vaccination rates with over 77 percent
of the population now fully inoculated
this includes adolescents over the age
of 12. there's a national recommendation
that they get the jab
like many other countries finland has
started to gradually lift remaining
covert 19 restrictions in the hope that
the nordic nation could soon return to
something resembling pre-pandemic life
if all goes well the finnish nasal spray
study will move to clinical trials this
autumn
but it will take months if not years to
determine whether the spray works
efficiently for humans
meanwhile mecula and her team will
continue their work
they're trying to get their nasal spray
labeled as a medical device rather than
a new drug to fast track its approval
our science reporter derek williams has
been following what scientists and
researchers have been doing during the
pandemic and as always he's here to
answer your questions
[Music]
this time elise h wants to know what's
happening with vaccines that can be
given via nasal sprays
the more than 20 covid19 vaccines that
are currently approved for use in in
some part of the world induce immunity
in a variety of different ways but they
all have one thing in common which is
that they're injected into a recipient's
muscle tissue
with a needle the body's immune system
therefore learns to recognize sars cov2
not where it would ordinarily encounter
at first
in the eyes or the nose or the throat
but in the upper arm
the shots provide fundamental systemic
protection but they don't prevent future
infection entirely
breakthrough infections in vaccinated
people have grown common since the onset
of the omicron variant
some experts think that to make the
immune system better at preventing
infection
and transmission
we need to develop vaccines that train
what are called your mucosal cells to
recognize the virus
mucosal cells are the cells that line
the upper reaches
of your respiratory tract so
it's the first place that your insides
come into contact with any viruses that
you might inhale
and the best way to train those cells so
the theory would be with a vaccine
that's sprayed or inhaled
rather than one that's injected
in the past researchers have tried to
design intranasal vaccines for other
respiratory diseases like influenza but
they're challenging for a couple of
reasons so success has been
pretty limited um one problem is that to
get the desired result in mucosal cells
nasal vaccine developers often choose to
use what are called
live attenuated viruses and
it can be really pretty tricky to get
the levels of those
just right
and because your nose is a lot closer to
your brain
than your upper arm is if there's an
inflammation or or other problems caused
by the vaccine there
then it's kind of by definition a more
dangerous situation
that said i i do think that intranasal
vaccines will eventually play a role in
controlling
the current pandemic but
what i think will have an even bigger
impact long term is the groundbreaking
research into this type of technology
that was driven by covet 19 which
could theoretically be deployed to fight
other respiratory diseases in the future
thanks to the pandemic working from home
is now part of everyday life in many
parts of the world for large and small
companies this meant upgrading computer
systems new software many young people
saw a huge opportunity and learned to
code to write programs for the new world
of work
in nigeria many responded quickly and
this entrepreneurship opened
professional opportunities including
with some international companies
work on his own terms
before the pandemic dairy had a regular
9-5 job as a software engineer in a
nigerian company
that required him going to an office
every day
but now he works remotely for a company
in europe
making what he made in one year in a
single month
the pandemics like our dollar store
my friends like it's like a blessing in
disguise for me to be honest because
like i said earlier like i never thought
um i could walk remotely i like i never
like i never envisaged that to be honest
until when the pandemic happened two
times a week dary meets with a small
group of fellow software engineers
called polytope labs
they come together to learn the latest
software technology
they all have remote jobs but they also
want to be part of what they believe is
the future of tech
sharon langley is the founder
he says software is africa's new oil
you know we have a lot of people here we
have a lot of bright minds here um
it's the only the only like opportunity
for us is to train these minds and make
them relevant
on like the global stage
members of polytope are part of a small
pool of nigerian senior software
developers that are in high demand all
over the world
so due to the pandemic and because most
companies were forced to start working
remotely most companies now come to
understand that you really do not need
your people to be in the office so it
has really
expanded the opportunities that are
available to talents down here um and it
also opened our eyes to see
what are those necessary skills we need
to start having we need to start
building ourselves on such that we can
now tap into these global opportunities
and everybody is happy
rita achebe is a talent recruiting
manager at talent ql
talent ql was created at the start of
the pandemic to match african tech
talents with international companies
rita says that they receive requests
from about a hundred companies every
month for senior developer roles
but many times it's difficult to fill
these roles because most software
developers in africa don't have the
relevant experience so they are not able
to take advantage of the vast
opportunities available
in order to close this gap talent ql
recently launched a digital academy
called old school
first of we start by deciding what
does the market what are the skills out
there that people are hiring for because
it doesn't make sense to
educate people on skills that are not
needed out there that is what a lot of
some of our traditional institutions do
all the lessons for old school are
recorded in this studio and then
uploaded to the online learning platform
around 8 000 people from 20 countries
applied for the program
6 000 got in
the goal is to train 1 million africans
in 5 years
if the african tech scene continues with
its current momentum
tech talents could become the
continent's biggest exports
the coronavirus pandemic has presented
us with huge challenges and we've
responded with innovations and
initiatives big and small maybe you also
have an idea up your sleeve then bring
it on even the smallest things can help
overcome big crises
next week we look at the economic
fallout of the pandemic
so until then goodbye from us and see
you soon
you